an accused drug kingpin linked to the  shooting of former Boston Red Sox great  David Ortiz has been arrested say czar  Emilio Peralta was taken into custody in  Colombia yesterday he had been wanted by  the FBI since late 2018 for a decade of  alleged drug trafficking Peralta was  rumored to have masterminded the  shooting attack that wounded David Ortiz  at a Dominican Republic bar in June  authorities there maintained Ortiz was  accidentally shot in a botched hit job  so shooting really had nothing to do  with him because we've never heard a  motive they didn't know they believed it  had nothing to do with they believe it  was a mistaken identity but still a lot  to come out he was shot in the back  talking about hazing and survived